[Musik]
sie sind ein eckpfeiler des
österreichischen bundesheeres die mit
soldatinnen und soldaten
[Musik]
die personen die bei bedarf die
informanten um als soldatinnen und
soldaten unser land zu schützen falls
die gruppengröße der gewinnst einheiten
im ernstfall zu erweitern
[Musik]
das besondere im milizsystem die aktuell
über 25.000 mit soldatinnen und soldaten
sind mitten in unserer bevölkerung ein
system das die österreicherinnen und
österreicher 2013 bei einer
volksbefragung mit starker mehrheit
befürwortet haben
doch welche aufgaben erfüllt die miliz
innerhalb des bundesheeres konkret die
ministerinnen und soldaten unterstützen
einsätze im inland bei denen besonders
viele kräfte über einen längeren
zeitraum benötigt werden wie zum
beispiel bei der militärischen
landesverteidigung bei
sicherheitspolizeilichen assistenz
einsetzen wie den job von wichtigen
objekten die bewachung von botschaften
grenzraum überwachung oder bei
katastropheneinsätzen um diese aufgaben
zu erfüllen stellen die miliz
soldatinnen und soldaten im bedarfsfall
viele selbstständige bataillone für
besonders schützenswerte objekte werden
außerdem eigene compagnie gebildet aus
miliz kräften der region
[Musik]
zusätzlich kann die mini bei bedarf
bestehende einheiten von beruf
soldatinnen und soldaten erweitern und
sie bei ihrem einsatz unterstützen
die zweite aufgabe der mini2
hochkomplexen einsätzen für die ein
besonderes expertenwissen benötigt wird
unterstützen sie als mit experten fast
ohne sehr so zum beispiel ein chemiker
mit speziellen kenntnissen als dritte
aufgabe beteiligt sich die mini
freiwillig an auslandseinsätzen die
vorteile des milizsystems die streits
fester des österreichischen bundesheeres
sind damit besonders stark in unserer
gesellschaft verankert
bernhard müller etwa arbeitete in seinem
zivilen alltag als anwalt und
verfassungsrechtler seit 25 jahren ist
er außerdem als soldat im einsatz als
stellvertretender kommandant der guitar
company tholen die compagnie drift ich
an wochenenden regelmäßig zur
freiwilligen übungen politik eigentlich
und was man damit auch gefehlt ist das
konzept des bürgers in uniform
man gibt es bei der ehrung von den
schulen wir verbringen zwar nur einen
teil und berufsleben beim ungefähr
versuchen aber trainer sind die derzeit
an der prozent oder mehr als gegeben hat
auch das befahren der realität wird
verschiedene büros und alter fruchten
vereint sind mit dem gemeinsamen einsatz
auftrag zu erfüllen
außerdem können durch das milizsystem in
kurzer zeit besonders viele soldatinnen
und soldaten in ganz österreich
mobilisiert werden
und da die miliz in ihrer regionalen
heimat verankert ist kennt sie ihre
einsatzgebiete besonders gut um diese
vorteile noch stärker nutzen zu können
mit dem lied jetzt vergrößert durch 5000
zusätzliche mini soldatinnen und
soldaten in ganz österreich
[Musik]
das österreichische bundesheer ein heer
von möglichkeiten mit sicherheit für uns
alle